Film Courage: Chad, you've said that you've made a
decision to have your life as an actor
and whatever ups and downs that brings
but do you look at your career as a
business? Chad Lindberg: Yes I do think that it's a
business they call it was a show
business not show friends it's a
business it's a very hard business but
it's very rewarding too if you're able
to break in and and do some of the great
projects that I've done I feel very
lucky but there is a business that comes
with it you got to make hard decisions
sometimes you have to part ways with you
know your agent or your manager or
somebody that you've built a
relationship with and you have to move
on and those are the worst conversations
to have they are awful especially me I I
take I take I take everything to heart
and I just don't take any relationship
granted for granted so yeah there are
hard choices and it it is a business
however if you can if you can focus on
your creativity and remind yourself of
why you're doing it and and the love
that you have for it the business part
so it's going to be there but it won't
become I don't think you should become
the main focus I think we should focus
on our creativity and then yeah we got
we got to play at a game - have you ever
had a friendship or an acquaintance sour
because they felt intimidated maybe they
felt like their accomplishments didn't
measure up with yours yeah
I've had I've had friends yeah the
family is a funny thing
that dead that gets sort of on the way
of friendships all the friendships I've
had have you should be happy for your
for your friends because their success
is my success my success is your success
I'm the same way on on Twitter and
Instagram like I'll boost up my friends
and hopefully they'll do the same for me
I mean that's why we're doing this we
have to lift each other up I've had
friends I've had a friend take his own
life because he didn't think he was good
enough I was somebody that I worked with
in this town and it's a reminder of
again where this place can take you if
you're not you know if you don't reach
out and it's sort of be like hey you
know you're not the only one that's
feeling this stuff so it's I've seen it
go tons of different ways I've seen
friends you know succeed I've seen
friends move back home I've seen friends
unfortunately pass on and you know it
happens you know it's it's a really hard
industry and and I again and I'll go
back to the guy today who wanted me to
get him into the business man you got to
be 110 percent about this business or
don't don't do it because it's it's just
so hard and but it's who you are then I
can't imagine doing anything else
so then pursue it yeah if you if you
can't imagine doing anything else and
you should absolutely pursue it and see
where it goes take a risk take a chance
you know I think that's why we're here
on this earth is to take chances
what if you learned about making money
as an actor and if that's too personal
no no no no I try to get my mom what
have you learned about making money as
an actor that it comes and goes very
quickly too quickly sometimes the the
main misconception that people have is
that actors are rich that we live you
know lavishly and some do some do you
know I think a very small percentage do
but you know for the majority of us
working actors you know we'll have a
little income come in and then
it's gone the next minute and it's tough
you know even at this point yeah and in
my career it's still hard and people
like oh you're rich and you're no I'm
not I'm really not um
again you know I'm not I'm not season
ten on a series that's been going on for
years I you know I am NOT so and so
that's making twenty million dollars a
picture it just doesn't picture what am
I like back in the day is now I'm
calling them pictures I think we should
go back to kind of pictures yeah but
yeah the most common misconception is
that we're rich and that's just not the
case and you know you know I'll find any
other way to bring that money in and
thank God there are residuals that keep
us alive you know and I found other ways
to bring an income but it's tough man
and I would say you know hang on to your
money if you get it and even I have a
problem with that you know because
there's no there's no study there's not
a steady job you know what I mean so
it's like when it comes in you feel like
you got to enjoy you know because you
don't know when it's going to come next
and you know even at this age I have to
learn to to hang on to it's because you
just don't know when it's going to when
you're gonna get paid again and it could
be you could you could get paid very
well or you know not get paid and you
got to respect the money yeah it's funny
if you do a search and Google search on
just any famous person or well-known
person those like the drop down
suggestions and so it'll it'll suggest
you know whether the person is married
or not and then inevitably like the
third thing is net worth it's just so
funny that everybody wants to know it it
is right
you